good morning believe nation today's
message is love what you do over to you
Matt Damon TV go you know the first job
I got was a real job besides commercials
and things like that local radio
commercials and things that kind of gave
us the money Ben and I had a joint bank
account we'd go to New York be and if
you made money acting you went into the
account and the account was only to be
used if if you were going to New York
for an audition or if we took ten
dollars out to like play video games and
I got a line in the movie mystic pizza
and the line was mom do you want my
green stuff and literally but it was a
scene that was a big dinner table scene
Julia Roberts it like a movie for her
and and it was this old dinner table
scene and so it took us three nights to
shoot and down in Mystic Connecticut and
I was a minor so my mother had to come
with me and you know we shot from five
to five every every night and and I just
remember being so in love with the
process of film I just know I was like
this is the greatest it was the best
time I've ever had in my life and it was
you know I was like this is amazing I
want this to never ever ever stop like I
loved it so this is a message has been
repeated over and over and over again on
the channel from actors to musicians to
entrepreneurs to investors to
politicians to athletes to like all over
the place the people who are at the top
of their field love what they do and it
feels like it's another video saying the
same thing but it's just so important
and I feel like so many people are not
doing what they love so many people are
doing the thing that they feel like they
have to do or that just pays the bills
and they've shut off that part of
themselves where they really enjoy the
work that they're doing and not every
day is going to be amazing and not every
task you do is going to be awesome but
net net there's got to be enough of what
you're doing on a daily basis that you
love if you're going to have any kind of
real success in this world and i
encourage you to explore until you
the thing that you just can't stop doing
you know for Matt Damon was doing acting
for me I remember doing a speech helping
helping some young Affairs out of the
YMCA and you know only three people
showed up and I've told the story a
number of times but I just felt so good
I can get lost in having discussion with
entrepreneurs and it just is so
rewarding and amazing and fulfilling and
for me as someone who's who's an
introvert believe it or not who doesn't
need to be surrounded by people who need
to have time by himself but if I find
out that you are an entrepreneur I am
hooked and I want to help you I don't
want to get you where you where you want
to go and I want to know what your dream
is and I want to know what impact you
want to have I just get so fired up it's
a thing that makes me come alive the
most and I'm so grateful that I've
discovered that and I encourage you to
go out and find that for yourself if you
haven't already if you have before and
you've lost some interest in it then
what's the pivot what's the change so
that the work that you're doing isn't
just okay but is great and you're
working on something that's really
inspiring you and really pushing you to
be better I think people just settle too
much I think people just don't make
their highest aspirations important
enough and so you settle for good and
you have a good life and you know the
goals you have are okay and if you don't
reach them you know whatever and you
just settle too much where when you find
something that you truly love you will
push yourself beyond what you thought
was possible to create something no one
even imagined before and that is
exciting and I deeply truly hopefully
want that for you as well so the
question today today is what is it that
you love the most doing what is it that
you can get lost in and just feel the
love of the work leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion I also wanted to give a
quick shadow to Oliver Kenda nado Oliver
thank you so much for buying my book it
means a lot to me those you're watching
you want to change at a shadow in their
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events vessel oh wait
expresso keep me go